نقلت صحيفه الوصف الجنرال عن مسؤولين ان
مستشاره الامن القومي الامريكي جيكس سلفا
اجرى محادثات سريه مع كبار مساعدي الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن في محاوله للحد من
مخاطر نشوب صراع اوسع حول اوكرانيا
ولتحذير موسكو من مغبه لجوء بوتن للسلاح
النووي او البيولوجي وقال المسؤولون ان
المحادثات السريه التي جرت في الاشهر
الاخيره بين سالبا ونظيره نيكولاي اتروشيف
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي
مساعد الرئيس الروسي تهدفوا للحد من مخاطر
التصعيد والابقاء القنوات مفتوحه وليست
لمناقشه تسويه للحرب
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤول امريكيه لصالبا
دال مسؤولين الاوكرانيين في زيارته
الاخيره لكيف لاظهار اشارات على الانفتاح
على الحديث بشانه حل النزاع